- I thought we should
end the interview right.
We only have a few minutes left,
so I'm gonna bring out some wine, okay?
- All right, yeah.
(wooing)
- I'm gonna ask y'all a bunch
of rapid-fire questions.
- Wow, oh this is--
- Thank you.
- Cheers.
- Yeah, I know.
We've got a good one.
(cheering)
Tell 'em about that,
this is your wine, right?
- Yeah.
- This is your wine.
- [Kimberly] It's ours.
- So, it's that, by Little
Big Town, Four Cellars.
- It's our wine.
- We also sell it in--
- Get it, in four, get it?
(laughing)
- See what we did there?
- Okay, this is a little thing
we like to call, "The Wine Down."
Okay, Philip, I'm gonna start with you,
who's most likely to pull a prank?
- Jimi.
- Why, what kind of pranks?
- He's always prankin'--
- But, you got him.
- Well, we all got him
good one time because
Karen, it was when Karen
was pregnant with their son.
- Real pregnant.
- Yeah.
- We were in the studio, and Jimi had a--
- I had nothing left to
give this baby, I was.
- [Kelly] I get it.
- She gave it all.
- Yep.
- So I said, "C'mon girls, we can pretend,
"And pretend like your
water broke," so we.
- Oh my God, that's mean.
- Jimi was in the bathroom.
- That is terrible, right?
- Jimi was--
- That's not a joke!
- And we were in the studio together,
and we took a water bottle
and poured some on the floor,
and when he came around from the bathroom,
we were like, Jimi--
- She was standing there and there
was water all over the floor,
I'm like, "What the freak?"
- Oh my gosh.
- Yeah.
- And then they all got to
watch you, that's so mean.
- I squealed so loud.
- He's hard to get, so.
- I love it, those are the best ones,
when you get them, my husband
and I do the same thing.
- [Philip] Yeah.
- Kimberly, who's the
messiest on the tour bus?
- Well, Philip, 'cause he spills a lot.
(laughing)
We call him Spillip.
- Probably 'cause he's drinking.
(laughing)
Karen, who's the biggest crier?
- Philip.
(laughing)
- He'd cry, yeah, he cries literally--
- Surely.
- Philip, I feel like you're getting
picked on a little here, man--
- [Karen] No.
- No, I'm--
- He's very emotional.
- I'm a close second.
- [Kelly] I'm a middler.
- Jimi's a close second.
- I love that it's not the women.
- [Karen] I know.
- [Kelly] It's so amazing.